le pass vaccinale ne passe
définitivement pas en vigueur depuis
lundi il impose d'être vacciné contre
locaux vides pour accéder à de nombreux
lieux comme les restaurants 1
contrairement à sa précédente version le
passé ni terre un test négatif ne permet
plus d'en bénéficier alors la
mobilisation perdure nice lille
strasbourg dans la capitale la
traditionnelle mobilisation menée par
florian philippot celle qui se dirige
vers le siège du laboratoire pfizer ou
encore les cortèges aux quatre coins de
paris se rappelle des gilets jaunes l'un
d'eux est d'ailleurs suivi par notre
reporter nadège abderrazak on la
retrouve tout de suite
bonjour à nadège alors quelle est
l'ambiance
à écouter à mirande vient tout juste
d'arriver place denfert rochereau
manifestation qui a débuté aux alentours
de 13 heures depuis la place de la
bastille alors on a pris un peu de temps
pour arriver jusqu'ici et bien parce que
les forces de l'ordre et quasiment dès
le départ n'a c'est le cortège et c'est
eux c'est elle qui ont rythmé la
manifestation quelques tensions ont été
sont à déplorer au moment où nous sommes
passés tout près de l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière pourquoi et bien parce que
les chez les jeunes avaient à coeur de
soutenir
najah ben farhat donc en fait c'est un
c'est le déclarant historique un des
manifestations d chez les jeunes et il a
été victime d'un accident de la route à
ces graves en début de semaine leur
détention qui ont conduit un les forces
de l'ordre et bien gaz et comme on dit
au sein des manifestations en gaz est
l'un des participants l'une des figures
des gilet jaune à faouzi lellouche vous
avez été victime vous avez reçu un petit
coup de spray au poivre tout à l'heure
c'est ça racontez-nous dans quelles
circonstances un petit coup de spray
c'est pas du parfum je peux vous dire
que voilà vous perdez la vue vous avez
du mal à respirer et ouais on a été
gazés gratuitement matraqué et opprimés
parce que tout simplement ils voulaient
pas qu'on aille voilà rendre hommage à
neiger qui à nos camarades depuis depuis
trois ans qui subit qui a subi une
opération qui a eu un accident donc tout
simplement c'est une affaire de 2,20 m
donc du coup la tension est montée
franchement soutien à camarades il
devrait comprendre et au lieu de ça gaze
et gazé à bout portant visé
volontairement et ce qui crée une
tension donc on a pu voir
défense de lord avec une disproportion
vraiment de force énormément de deux
policiers un encadrement qui n'est pas
légal tout simplement parce que depuis
le début et j'étais en colère jordi j'ai
accepté de déclarer ce parcours à la
simple condition qu'il n'y ait pas de
menaces mobiles on est menacé depuis le
départ de bastille
et à la fin on ou gaz et on nous
matraque je suis désolé ils veulent
qu'on les respecte ils respectent pas la
loi même comment vous expliquez que les
gilets jaunes
bénéficient entre guillemets d'un
traitement de faveur différent des
autres manifestants
comment vous l'expliquez sais ce que
c'est une mesure de précaution de la
préfecture qui se dit qu'à pas avec les
gilet jaune ya un risque important que
la manifestation dérape la mesure de
protection à la baudot ça s'appelle de
la discrimination
y'a pas un cortège aujourd'hui n'importe
lequel en france qui a encadré comme le
nôtre c'est un droit fondamental la
liberté d'expression de pouvoir
manifester
c'est pas fou et on est muselée on nous
empêche d'avancer librement de sortir
pour consommer de sortir pour aller aux
toilettes de sortir tout simplement
quand on le veut de cette nasse qui est
mobile la cour européenne
la constitution interdit la nasse le
droit interdit la nasse des pourtant et
la pratique il a pratiqué de quel droit
ils ont peur oui ils ont peur de nous
ils ont peur de la parole citoyenne qui
dit non aux décisions politiques qui
prennent parce qu'elles sont inadaptées
et du coup les dérangeons les jeunes ils
doivent par faire respecter la loi on
n'a pas tous les mêmes droits en france
toute la population elle a les mêmes
droits mais pourquoi il y aurait cette
stigmatisation est cette discrimination
concernant lés gens concernant nos
manifestants si à moins de monde dans
les cortèges de jeunes vous pensez que
c'est à cause justement de ces
conditions d'encadrement des
manifestations mais c'était évident
comment les gens vont avoir envie de
venir avec nous en leur montrant des
images de manifestants qui revendiquent
de simples citoyens leurs droits et qui
sont gazés nas et réprimandé pour
certains condamnés mutilés c'est juste
la continuité de ce qui fait macron
depuis son quinquennat depuis trois ans
où on a beau contester les décisions qui
sont prises parce que la rue elle sert à
ça ou alors sinon c'est le bulletin de
vote tous les cinq ans mais il s'en fout
il continue à appliquer une politique
inadaptée qui favorise une catégorie de
gens bien riche et qui soumis une autre
partie à l' esclavage on n'est pas des
vaches à lait on n'est là que pour les
entretenir et ben non ils sont là
normalement au service de la population
c'est pas nous qui sommes au service des
élus normalement ils sont là pour
répondre ils sont là pour nous
représenter donc les invisibles disent
non depuis trois ans aujourd'hui on veut
dissuader les gens d'aller dans nos
manifestations et de dire qu'on n'est
pas d'accord avec leur décision
tout simplement merci merci beaucoup
enfin aussi lellouche pour ce nouveau
témoignage aujourd'hui donc on vous
l'avez entendu
lellouche qui est assez en colère
aujourd'hui encore après l'encadrement
policier l'encadrement des forces de
sécurité qui est bien une fois encore
n'a pas été respecté un selon les dires
de de faouzi lellouche en accord avait
été conclu avec la préfecture de police
de paris pour éviter cette menace
constante il n'a pas elle n'a pas été
respectée donc voilà voilà ce qu'on peut
dire sur cette manifestation aujourd'hui
qui touche à sa fin puisque on est
arrivés place denfert rochereau à des
manifestants qui comme chaîne chaque
samedi ont une nouvelle fois manifesté
contre la hausse et des prix du
carburant d énergie et de certaines
matières premières
manifestations également contre le pass
vaccinale qui est entré en vigueur cette
semaine
merci à la dèche pour toutes ces
précisions